welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of
spider-man no way home a true
spider-verse event that start to finish
is a love letter to the web slinger's
full cinematic history not only by
bringing back past peter parker's
but in even subtler ways echoing little
moments that prove how despite all these
guys different backgrounds these dorks
were destined across paths and rescue
each other so i'm gonna break this down
scene by scene for everything you might
have missed and folks i think i found
more easter eggs in this movie than i
have in anything i've ever broken down
on this channel in five years before we
begin you can celebrate spider-man no
way home by checking out our awesome
merch at new rockstarsmerch.com with
this amazing new limited edition shirt
one of my favorite shirts epic hero shop
has ever made called strange
entanglement i can't wait to get mine
it's gonna be my favorite christmas gift
you can get yours at
newrockstarsmerch.com and thank you to
baksu for sponsoring this video more on
them later okay the opening marvel
studios title card has been updated
slightly so that if you look closely on
the whole of the r replacing rocket
who's in recent mcu titles is now peter
parker the moment he came back through
that portal to join cap and end game
this movie will also make grown men cry
seeing spider-man arrive through portals
twice so we open immediately where far
from home left off the audio of the news
broadcast of j jonah jameson's daily
bugle revealing peter parker's identity
by mysterio's doctored footage director
john watts recreated that 2019 scene to
near perfect detail before ended by
cutting off peter's f-bomb
which itself was a callback to aunt
may's final line in homecoming
but now a car horn censors out the word
and mj is once again in her joan of arc
shirt but the three extras behind her
are dressed exactly like the three guys
behind mj in the far from home scene but
the one major difference is that mj now
wears the broken black dahlia necklace
that peter bought her and venice and
gave to her in london
i actually like it better broken this
necklace is the key to peter and mj's
relationship because in the final scene
despite her memory of peter being erased
something compels her to keep wearing
that proof that she wasn't just with
peter because he was spider-man and that
she will wait forever for that i love
you because she likes things better
broken notice how one of the onlookers
says you're just a kid just like one of
the onlookers on the train says in
spider-man 2 when that peter got
unmasked he's
just a kid peter swings mj through times
square where jameson's inescapable
broadcast includes an image of peter's
face half covered as it often is in
spider-man comics and they pass two
billboards for rogers the musical the
captain america musical from hawkeye on
disney plus peter lands mj on the
queensboro bridge where they are spotted
by passengers on the nearby roosevelt
island tramway famous from the 2002 sam
raimi spider-man film as the setting of
the final battle where green goblin made
peter choose between mary jane or sather
the children and then right after
getting that toby error reference we get
an andrew garfield error reference when
peter thwips the manhole cover recalling
the very last time we saw andrew
garfield on screen as spider-man this is
in front of del mar's deli in queens
peter's favorite spot that showed up in
homecoming and in a deleted scene and
far from home but notice how it now
reads del mar's three for this being the
third tom holland spider-man movie back
in their apartment it made dumps happy
oh but then they walk in on mj and peter
d clothed calling back aunt may walking
in on peter and ned just like this in
homecoming but john watts shoots all of
this in a full two minute long take to
heighten that awkwardness in kudos to
these four actors because the timing is
so precise like when peter fails to
close the window shade the first time he
then swifts it shut which feels
improvised like tom holland screwed up
closing it the first time but then it
was just like oh peter could flip it and
then they added in the vfx of the
webbing after that also notice how peter
wears the same i survived my trip to nyc
shirt that he wore in homecoming as he
came back home after mr stark
confiscated his suit it's less baggy on
him now because our little guy is grown
up the daily bugle broadcasts hammer
away at peter you see a daily news front
page photoshopping mug shots using their
yearbook photos and revealing mj's name
as michelle jones watson for the first
time adding the watson like her
counterpart mary jane watson time
magazine calls him iron man junior and
shows him crying like a baby in touch
weekly calls him too faced and then
peter gets doused in green paint while
newsreel footage of tower bridge
includes the ticker political turmoil
continues in new asgard huh so i guess
valkyrie's rule over that colony in
tonsburg norway might be a bit unstable
something we could see more of in thor
love and thunder investigators recovered
the drones from far from home linking
them to stark giving investigators
grounds to arrest peter the dodc returns
department of damage control who cleaned
up avenger messes and homecoming now led
by agent clary albert cleary is the dodc
comptroller in the comics they take some
evidence photos showing a framed photo
of ned and mj from the homecoming dance
interesting how peter is not in that
picture though keep that in mind we see
peter star wars figurines there's a
photo taken of the iron spider charging
station without the suit in it though
can you see all the tangle of plugs into
that one wall outlet also we see the
edith classes that mysterio was trying
to steal from him and a bunch of
playstation games because sony during
the interrogation peter wears the
physics or theoretical but the fun is
real shirt that he wore in spider-man
homecoming when tony stark dropped him
off back in queens asian cleary says
fury's been off planet for the past year
so peter thought he was talking to fury
during far from home but he was actually
talking with the skrull talos also
confirming that the dodc is more aware
of fury's movements than most avengers
are also that agent cleary just made my
list of skrull specious ahead of secret
invasion because how else would he know
that stark industries the company itself
gets swept up in the investigation so uh
oh i guess morgan stark's gonna have to
go to public school the file photo they
use of happy hogan was his look from
iron man 3 prologue in 1999 when he had
long hair and bolo tie like vincent vega
and pulp fiction and blowing our minds
in the first 10 minutes they get legal
counsel from freaking charlie cox matt
murdock daredevil from the netflix
series a crossover even crazier than
toby and andrew in my book because a
this is permanent in the mcu and b it
presents wilder implications for the mcu
suggesting that much if not all of what
we saw in the netflix marvel shows could
now be mcu canon and we just saw cox's
co-star vincent d'onofrio appearing as
kingpin in hawkeye and that finale
episode will apparently give us some
clarity on the exact canonicity of all
those stories but to be clear this matt
murdock is the super power daredevil a
brick flies zen through the window and
he catches it with lightning fast
reflexes but i love how peter's hand was
also ready to catch that brick too since
he has spidey sense also fun fact john
fabro played foggy nelson in the 2003
daredevil cool so they have to move into
happy's condo where he swiped tony's
dumb e robot that we saw in the first
iron man film also recovered in iron man
3 and we saw happy yelling at it in
homecoming now first on the tv there are
some people complaining about the new
changes to the statue of liberty which i
agree why would you add cap shield do it
also while they're in the condo happy
watches downton abbey just as he did in
iron man 3 when he's in recovery and by
the door he has a bunch of spare
security badges hanging this was after
he lectured everyone in iron man 3 that
they have to have their one badge on
them at all times as peter and mj
facetime in mj's room hangs her sketches
of peter with a rain cloud over his head
but also that one of coach wilson from
homecoming why are you here you don't
even have detention oh i i know i just
like coming here to sketch people in
crisis
it's you
there's also that same photo of her and
ned from homecoming again without peter
in it and a photo of pigeons and venice
and on the bed behind her she is reading
maya angelou's i know why the caged bird
sings in this conversation peter
mentions his spider bite ever since i
got bit by that spider i've only had one
week where my life has felt normal this
is actually only the second time in the
mcu that peter really referenced that
bite after his chat with ned in
homecoming you got bit by a spider can
you bite me
well it probably would have hurt right
you know what whatever even if it did
hurt i'll let it bite me
maybe how much did the spider's dead ned
betty brant hosts the midtown morning
news still a job that she apparently
also balances with being an intern for
the daily bugle and tick-tock and she
says go get him tiger marry jane's
catchphrase or peter in the comics and
in the past films also you can hear
someone in the crowd yelling do a flip
just like that guy in homecoming
who also came back in shanghai the
protesters signs include several
pro-mysterio ones one calling peter
devil in disguise so this movie's
premise is loosely based on the
spider-man one more day comic nyh peter
goes to doctor strange in search of a
spell to make everyone forget that he's
spider-man but ends up having to turn to
a little girl who has revealed as
methesto to do this instead it actually
ends with a similar reset as this film
in which peter's identity is a secret
once more but at the cost of his
relationships with mj and with his
friend it was a very controversial comic
when it came out but like many great mcu
movies it turned a pretty divisive comic
storyline into a really great work of
cinema in the crowd there's also an mj
supporter this is a cameo by darnell
applane an actor and zendaya's real life
assistant flash has published a tell-all
book called flashpoint which is probably
a nod to the dc comics preceding
timeline crossover event with barry
allen meeting alternate versions himself
and a batman which is being adapted into
another cross franchise event with the
flash in 2022. the school's mural of
great inventors throughout history that
showed howard stark in homecoming has
also now added the faces of abraham
erskine who is the inventor of cap super
soldier serum as well as hank pym in the
upper right corner coach wilson mr dell
and mr harrington greet peter with a
display case of peter's academic
decathlon awards and his blazer there's
also a photo of peter and mj in venice
where it looks like mr harrington might
have pasted himself in from one of his
selfies that he took then later on the
rooftop mj reads a new york post that is
the salacious tabloid that they actually
based the earlier daily bugle designs on
reading peter parker and his spider
minions showing peter puppeting ned and
mj below reading his hypnotic spider
senses seduced jones watson male spiders
actually do release hypnosis like
pheromones and ironically peter does
allow mj and ned to be brainwashed but
to forget about him peter rolls over to
kiss her and the textbook that he rested
his head on was chemistry i see what you
did there that we wouldn't notice but we
did also written a graffiti on the
background is ditko a reference to
spider-man co-creator steve ditko peter
gets rejected from college after college
dumb e gradually reassembles peter's
death star until the mit one comes in
and dummy just breaks it just like ned
did and all three of the friends get
rejected which is a bummer because mit
is tony stark's alma mater where he
handed out scholarships in civil war and
where future iron heart rierie williams
goes to school the witch string lights
actually have little goatees making them
little doctor strangest giving peter the
idea of what avenger to return to and we
hear the notes of doctor strange's theme
here that leads peter 21778 bleaker
street the sanctum sanctorum inside one
of the shoveling apprentices is played
by emily fong who worked production on
infinity war and game chung chi and
black widow wong arrives and explains
how one of the rotunda gateways opened
to siberia and led a blizzard in we saw
those gateways in the 2016 film i will
say the productions movie went to an
insane amount of effort to freeze over
the sanctum for just a oh left the door
open to siberia gag i'm wondering with
those flood waters pouring into the
sanctum and the multiverse of madness
teaser this may be a bigger indicator of
this reality destabilizing strange
floats in wearing a columbia university
hoodie colombia is his alma mater we see
another one of these hoodies floating by
the laundry machines downstairs and he's
carrying a mug reading oh for fox's sake
we learned that wong actually holds the
rank of sorcerer supreme since strange
blipped for five years since wandavision
told us that scarlet witch's powers
surpassed those of the sorcerer supreme
that might mean strange might be even
lower on that sorcerer hierarchy than we
thought it might need her help even more
strange says that peter's request to
reverse time is selfish plus the time
stone was atomized but peter says quote
it's not about me i mean this is really
hurting a lot of people in doing so
peter uses the same words that the
ancient one used in her crucial lesson
is strange it's not about you and so
strange agrees to help him using a spell
called the runes of kafka not sure the
spelling but kafka isn't from any of the
comics that i know of but what wong says
the memory wiping spell travels the dark
border between known and unknown
realities suggesting that to enact the
spell you have to kind of bridge with
other realities of the multiverse and he
leaves them through a portal you can see
that bell tower in the background that's
actually in the camartage courtyard
strange explains how the sanctum is
built at an intersection of cosmic
energy currents that they weren't the
first to seek this out with walls
thousands of years old and that they
shot an episode of the equalizer there
in the 80s the spell goes crazy and
peter shouts basically everyone who knew
that i was spider-man before should
still know that is the rule by which
characters get warped into this reality
also suggesting that kirsten dunst mary
jane both harry osborn several others
might have also been briefly walking
around in the mcu but also tells us that
venom through his multiversal symbiote
hive mind must have known that peter is
spider-man though i didn't know when
elektro found out that peter was
spider-man unless there's some kind of
spider-man mandela effect that i'm
suffering from it's possible as this
purple void surrounds them strange sees
a glowing silhouette that looks like the
glowing arms of doc ock him being one of
the characters that are currently
spilling into this reality so strange
has to encase this spell in a prism
similar to how strange and what if in
cases killmonger infinity and zola
ultron in a prism to contain that
reality rupturing chaos but this prism
is a dodecadron which is made up of
pentagons with five sides and five
corners because peter changed his spell
five times strange thought it was six
but if you listen back peter changed it
for mj for ned for aunt may for happy
and then for everyone who knew that's
fine so what was the sixth well the six
may have been a secret change by doctor
strange so that he would still remember
peter because he loves him at least
that's my feeling peter suits up in the
iron spider armor using extra wings to
glide the bridge and inside his heads up
display you can read up in the corner
edith offline also the voices changed to
mail and that's because the dodc is
confiscated and disabled all the drone
network it's interesting that they did
not take this iron spider suit too but
again when they raided his place that
suit was not charging in the port so i
don't know maybe peter tried to flush
the nanotech down the toilet now on this
bridge there are a ton of license plates
and i can tell you folks i looked at all
of them because john watts loves to hide
easter eggs in his license plates the
only ones i could actually decode mean
anything were a nissan with
s-e-y-s-1 dp and earlier there was an
anagram book on peter's shelf so this
plate rearranges to spidey's plural
which could be a clue for multiple
spideys being in this movie and of
course the mit woman's car is
63a5m3 or 63 asm 3 4 1963 amazing
spider-man number three the comic debut
of doctor octopus who arrives in the
scene played once more by alfred molina
from the 2004 spider-man 2 he looks
awesome composer michael g samples danny
elfman's doc theme from that film and as
his claws smashed through this bridge
note that the claws light up red which
in that 2004 film was how we knew when
the claws were controlling otto's brain
so this must have happened before peter
converted him at which point the lights
flickered back white doc ogg brings up
his machine here his fusion device that
he was working on in the movie what have
you done with my machine and he quotes
his line from the 2004 film his whole
goal the power of the sun
in the palm of my hand now at one point
you'll notice peter webs one of the
claws to a car door to make it harder
for dock to grab anything else to throw
at him doc ock pries off some of peter's
nanotech which then absorbs onto his
arms so if you remember back to the
first raimi film norman osborne was an
expert on nanotech i'm something of a
scientist myself i read all your
research on nanotechnology really
brilliant and in the sequel octavius
built his arms using oscorp tech i'd
like to thank harry osborne and ozcorp
industries for providing it and he
explained how he controls these arms
using a neural link these smart arms are
controlled by my brain through a neural
link
nanowires feed directly into my
cerebellum and since the stark nanotech
is controlled nearly as well that would
allow doc oxtech to be compatible with
it however that link goes both ways so
peter is able to pair with the arms and
control the arms remotely and then otto
snaps at his arm saying listen to me
calling back what he said at the end of
the 2004 film listen to me now then
green goblin swoops in but doctor
strange portals them back to the crypt
where the lizard is already contained
doc asked strange if this is a birthday
party just like tony stark referenced dr
straj's jimmy kimmel bit when they first
met what is your job exactly besides
making balloon animals peter enlists mj
and ned ned asks doctor strange how did
you know you were made of magic because
my nana says that we have it in our
family and sometimes i get these
tinglings in my hands you should talk to
your physician aha and later nana's home
has a display of ancient blades and ned
successfully operates the sling ring
which surprises strange so yes it really
does seem like ned might have a future
as a sorcerer in the mcu then down in
the undercroft there's all kinds of
creepy goodies a doll turns its head at
them in the fridge are a bunch of
creatures a floating eyeball in a jar a
claw creeping out from under foil mj
finds a goatee guard that strange must
use to get his goatee perfectly shaved
and then mj goes on tick tock to find
people on homemade gliders replicating
green goblin another with a frost giant
cosplay that reads i am the green elf
and then at the end of this they're
finally able to track down electro where
peter also finds sandman battling
electro with his suit turned inside out
salmon helps peter because they were on
good terms at the end of the 2007 film
but electro jamie foxx now has a new
body looking a bit cooler and while dr
connors later calls it out since they
didn't know each other while they worked
at oscorp in the same continuity this
new body is never really explained in
the movie meanwhile willem dafoe norman
osborne my favorite actor in this movie
argues with his goblin helmet just as he
would in the 2002 film but the argument
ends with him shattering the helmet but
even after it shatters the goblin voice
laughs meaning breaking that helmet did
not destroy the identity it just fused
it into norman's soul notice the framing
of this broken mask as norman walks away
matches the framing of toby maguire
peter leaving his suit behind in the
garbage can in the 2004 film but in both
cases the characters get dragged back
into the game you know as i am looking
for all these details i like to keep my
snack game going but i'm tired of the
same old snacks which is why i have
turned to baksu boksu is a monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
straight from japan to your door each
themed monthly baksu box takes you on a
gourmet journey through japan bok su is
the only company that partners with 100
year old family snack makers for genuine
and authentic selections the first box
you get is called seasons of japan and
lets you taste the seasonal flavors that
are popular in japan this month we got
fancy and upgraded to this limited
edition handcrafted kiribaku wooden box
let's see what's inside
so cool
you start off with this kanto new year
culture guide that tells you everything
that's in here oh and i got these little
gummies these are so good
look at these look at these
they're just like yummy sour strawberry
flavor you can't you honestly don't find
anything quite like this anywhere else i
love them they're little hearts which
mean they love me back
there's all kinds of stuff in here like
little chocolate snacks
little puff things
but yeah each box suit comes with a
beautifully designed booklet that tells
you all about the snacks where they come
from and each month features new
curations centered around a theme i am
lucky to have traveled to japan in the
past but if you have someone in your
life who longs to travel but might not
be able to right now this is an awesome
gift idea it's also just a great gift
for people who love snacks and you would
also be giving them the chance to win
two free tickets to japan because baksu
is having a giveaway everyone who
subscribes before december 31st is
automatically entered so if you want to
try some awesome japanese snacks and
help support our channel click the link
in the description and use our code new
rockstars to get 28 off your
subscription peter returns to the feast
facility that's the homeless center
where peter works in the comics and the
games someone tagged the sign outside
with mysterio was right in a green
circle over peter's head just like
mysterio's fishbowl helmet inside norman
plays a convincing mentally disturbed
man saying someone's at my house oscorp
doesn't exist my son he trails off
referring to harry osborne of course but
also telling us that oscorp at least any
company named that is not currently in
the mcu anywhere notice how he wears a
green coat over those purple sweats
goblins colors meanwhile aunt mae's
costume is worth looking at she's
wearing a blue jumper with a red sash
that could be foreshadowing the bloody
wound that causes her death aunt may
tells peter to help norman peter says
this isn't my problem which she gets mad
at him over because it recalls toby
mcguire peter's fateful decision not to
intervene which led to uncle ben's death
i miss the part where that's my problem
j jonah jameson's upgraded daily bugle
show which is really thanks to his
spider-man coverage now pushes
supplements which is another jab at alex
jones the chiron reads why does
spider-man hate national monuments
recalling the washington monument and
homecoming and tower bridge apart from
home meanwhile otto octavius recalls the
moment he warped saying he had
spider-man by the throat so this must
have happened right before toby changed
him in this moment in the film these
things have turned you into something
you're not
don't listen to them it was my dream
sometimes to do what's right we have to
be steady and give up the thing we want
the most even our dreams
you're right
meanwhile max talks about being absorbed
into the grid about to turn into pure
energy recalling the amazing spider-man
2 when peter and gwen hardwired elektro
to that grid and overloaded his chip and
then lizard asks max if he dies but he
never gets an answer and that's because
lizard doesn't actually die in the 2012
film he ends up locked up and approached
to join a future sinister six so strange
shows them the box the machina dicadomus
in latin roughly the division machine
which he could use to send them back to
their universes but peter and strange
debate over this strange says in the
grand calculus of the multiverse their
sacrifice means infinitely more than
their lives the subtext of course being
his guilt for sacrificing tony stark as
part of his complex calculus from seeing
14 605 future outcomes to defeat thanos
if you think about it calculus was also
the type of arithmetic on he who remains
chalkboard and i just find it
interesting that peter overcomes strange
by doing simpler geometry it's still
super nerdy just not overthinking it
doing as much 4d chess as those guys are
so peter snatches the box and strange
pursues him trapping him between portals
so that he whips his own foot i love it
but then he brings peter back to push
his astral soul from his physical body
similar to how the ancient one did to
him however peter's soulless physical
body still manages to evade strange
interesting this must be a higher form
of the spidey sense which would be a
neurological reflex that is divorced
from peter's conscious mind but also
shows us how this is really linked to a
kind of metaphysical magic and later in
the movie andrew garfield peter does say
magic's real here too so he might be
aware of that link as well strange sends
the cloak of levitation after peter
giving us that what if spider-man became
the sorcerer's supreme image from the
comics that we also saw in the zombie
episode of what if i love this detail on
a nearby newsstand are people magazines
with liz allen peter's crush from
spider-man homecoming daughter to adrian
tomb's vulture calling peter a liar
showing us that that family including
vulture is still somewhere in the
multiverse and gonna show up in morvius
don't know how that's gonna make sense
strange traps peter in the mirror
dimension the vfx are incredible peter
tumbles past the high line in new york
city which kate bishop actually just
recommended to elena and hawkeye he
tumbles through a department store where
he can hear christmas music playing
peter tumbles toward the bethesda
fountain in central park actually looks
like the angel of water statue might
have like the statue of liberty been
swapped out for an avenger strange traps
peter in an endless loop of portals
creating the illusion of infinite
spider-man as there are and then peter
recognizes from the archimedean spiral
that he can geometry the [ __ ] out of
this and trap strange in a web of math
and again if you want a way to really
celebrate this awesome magic versus math
moment you gotta get your hands on our
exclusive strange entanglement shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com norman offers to
help peter saying you know i'm something
of a scientist myself of course his line
from the 2002 movie you know i'm
something of a scientist myself peter
and ned do their recurring handshake and
it ends with the sling ring sparking a
bit a little sign that ned does have a
kind of inner magic to him peter takes
them to happy's condo the security feed
glitches as electro passes from his
interference and then auto snaps i don't
need fixing especially by some teenager
using scraps and a bachelor's drunk
drawer it's not a drawer full of scraps
it's a bunch of scraps on the walls of
happy's room you can actually see the
name slot that's a reference to
long-time spider-man writer dan slott
peter activates the stark tech
fabricator we saw this kind of device
used on the stark jet to design his new
suit and far from home it's powered by
an arc reactor this is a familiar design
this is the new element arc reactor mark
1 with the triangular inlay that tony
stark constructed using the new element
he rediscovered in iron man 2. i love
that this is the era of arc reactor he
used because in spider-man homecoming
they specifically had the mark 42 armor
that was using that same generation of
arc reactor from iron man 3 on the stark
jet so that would be the one that happy
still has in his possession meanwhile
otto and may share some water in the
kitchen they did briefly date in the
comics then peter designs a new
inhibitor trip for doc och to replace
the one that got fried in the 2004 film
and he puts in place these six needles
that go into otto's skin and fuse with
the spinal cord i love how they use the
same exact production design from the
rainy films for all of these pieces of
technology they really clearly did their
homework to look at how all of these
things functioned at this point the red
lights on dock's claws flicker back to
bluish white and he transfers the
nanotech back to peter to give him this
golden spider eight arms just like his
own it's like giving him a badge of
honor there otto encourages his buddy
norman that he's about to rid himself of
his darker half but norman facing away
from him says just me and defoe uses his
darker goblin voice in this moment
meaning it is only goblin in his mind
right now and so peter's spidey sense
kicks in and he just kind of wanders
around the condo it's super creepy and
notice as it begins the first person to
appear in his periphery is norman
osborne and the first thing peter says
is mei it's his instinct telling him
that norman will post a fatal threat to
may and so peter whips norman to dummy
which as they came into the condo you
could see norman in the background
casing so goblin makes his case to the
other villains these are not curses
these are gifts recalling the final
lines of the 2002 film the lesson that
toby maguire peter learned this is my
gift
my curse
when peter had to rationalize his powers
as both a gift and a curse the fight
breaks out peter punches goblin and
goblin just smiles more and more he is
loving it combat is just so brutal
apparently willem dafoe insisted on
doing as many stunts as he could himself
and downstairs goblin's glider strikes
may and now that creepy face is covered
in a hobgoblin style hood and he tosses
a pumpkin bomb which peter bats away
showing how this goblin is just as
willing to bomb an aunt may as he was in
the 2002 film and as she dies may says
the immortal words of uncle ben with
great power there must also come great
responsibility yeah there was a slight
rewording and that's because she said
the original comic wording of the line
that includes there must also come
directly from stan lee folks that hit
hard so to cheer us up ned uses the
sling ring to portal to one of the other
peter parkers currently in this universe
spider-man andrew garfield a guy no one
will ever believe again in interviews
notice the music in this moment is
actually james horner's young peter
theme from the amazing spider-man film
in 2012. and we just got to pause and
appreciate how great the intro garfield
era of the spider-man suit was i mean
it's definitely my favorite
aesthetically great shade of blue huge
eyes and a true diy practicality to it
one thing that era nailed but then ned
portals again and toby maguire peter
parker steps in his entrance set to
danny elfman's spider-man theme and we
gotta credit both maguire and garfield
for so deathly slipping back into their
mannerisms toby is preemptively polite
and dopey andrew is post-mistake
apologetic and super chatty and i also
like how their first instinct upon
seeing each other is to thwhip attack as
if the last time either of these guys
encountered a doppelganger it might have
been a hostile situation toby peter says
that he liked to hang out atop the
chrysler building as we saw his peter
perch in the rainy films andrew peters
says he'd like the empire state building
for the few but they find peter on the
rooftop of his school in queens it's not
about the view it's about a refuge from
his high school life you see never moved
into the city andrew peters starts to
say he has some understanding of losing
someone of course referring to letting
gwen stacy die and he goes on to
describe what happened after gwen's
death how he stopped pulling his punches
and got rageful and bitter so apparently
in that garfield continuity this
spider-man might have straight-up killed
people which is an insane revelation i'm
gonna explore all that in another video
but toby peter recounts the vengeance
that he felt that led him to track down
uncle ben's murderer and how in
spider-man 3 that wound was reopened
with flint marco and exacerbated by
venom a critical lesson that he had to
learn and all three recognized the words
with great power comes great
responsibility making that proverb a
kind of constant absolute point among
all the spider-men they return to the
high school and work together to
engineer cures for all of them i love
how nerdy the second half of this movie
is toby peter tells ned that his best
friend died in his arms after trying to
kill him referring to harry osborne and
spider-man 3 meanwhile toby peter tells
andrew peter that he and mary jane
eventually made it work ned calls for
peter and all three of them look up
confusedly pointed at each other of
course a nod to the meme awesome and
toby peters shows how his webbing unlike
the others used mechanical web shooters
comes freakishly out of his wrists i
love how andrew plays super grossed out
and even when tom holland moves the
conversation along he even continues
staring at toby's wrist for a beat
before he's like oh okay yeah what and
then on to the showdown at the statue of
liberty toby peter's back tenses up a
callback to peter herting is back in the
2004 film which itself was an inside
joke about how toby nearly sit out of
the sequel after hurting his back on
seabiscuit and then andrew cracks it for
him for once cracking someone's backbone
without killing them
toby talks about how he fought an alien
made out of black goo of course
referring to venom his eddie brock
played by topper grace and setting up
tom hardy venom's arrival in the
post-credits scene and then tom holland
peter talks about how he fought thanos
and then she was like i'm lame i only
fought a russian guy in a rhinoceros
suit course referring to paul giamatti's
rhino but i love it toby peter talks him
up saying he's actually amazing giving
andrew garfield the credit he deserves
despite his amazing spider-man era often
ranked the lowest by fans he's still
amazing and now he's got his brothers
but i love how the first time these
feeders try to work together it totally
fails since they are more used to being
solo acts so while andrew and toby teach
tom how to mourn and to forgive tom
teaches them the one thing his era of
spider-man had that theirs didn't
cooperation with superheroes more
powerful than he is at one point toby
just straight up screams how is this
helping and andrew peter asks if the
avengers are a band and calling back
when bruce banner asked if the avengers
broke up like the beatles avengers broke
up we're toast like a band like like the
beatles but they're able to figure it
out and a little subtle detail here that
i loved during their heroic swing tom
holland peter
whips to his two brothers to sling them
back up with him so that the three of
them can leap together off the statue of
liberty head right at electro in sandman
and lizard meanwhile you see how
elektra's bolts at one point higher up
in a star shape around his head like
elektro's mask in the comics toby peter
manages to revert thomas hayden church
flint marco i love how the device lights
up and spins the same way the super
collider did in spider-man 3 then lizard
jumps into the portal with ned and mj
thrashing around that science lab
evoking that school battle in the 2012
film but then doc ock helps them fix
electro and they hit lizard with the
same serum gas that they used as the
reigning antidote at the end of the 2012
movie reverting him to rhys ivan's dr
connors and max dillon tells andrew
garfield peter that he thought he was
going to be black and that there's got
to be a black spider-man somewhere out
there definitely setting up miles
morales to step up sometime soon
hopefully since we do know from aaron
davis's lines and homecoming that miles
morales does exist in the mcu i don't
want those weapons in this neighborhood
i got a nephew who live here yeah sorry
miles i'm not gonna make it then green
goblin dives in snarling can the
spider-man come out to play calling back
his creepy line to toby maguire peter
over the phone in the 2002 film
can spiderman come out to play and he
bombs the box causing the spell to spill
out around liberty island i love how the
vfx caused that tear to turn something
that should be in the deep background
feel like a canvas that is way closer to
us and in this chaos mj slips and falls
from the scaffolding the framing exactly
matching gwen stacy's slo-mo death drop
in 2014 scaring the hell out of all of
us tom holland peter dives after her but
he gets swiped by goblin so it's up to
andrew garfield peter to step up to
catch her redeeming his failure to save
gwen but they do it in a really cool way
because notice this time he focuses more
on the leap itself to catch her in his
arms instead of trying to snatch her
with his webbing all to avoid that
whiplash that actually caused gwen to
die proving that this poor guy has been
obsessing over that decision every day
of his life and that is why he sobs and
relief finally we get another little
source for our setup for ned when the
cloak of levitation catches them we
actually get a little light motif of
doctor strange's theme music there too
get this man a cloak and then on the
fallen giant captain america shield tom
holland peter and goblin duke it out and
it is vicious peter prepares to kill
goblin lifting his glider to bring down
on him the same way captain america
nearly killed iron man in civil war
using the tool that peter is now
standing on this kid is moments away
from going full john walker but toby
maguire peter jumps in grabs the glider
even though tom holland peter shoves
that glider even closer to him
ultimately he helps him see the light
and to make a different choice and so
tom holland proves his change by hitting
norman with the anti-serum and giving
him a second chance meanwhile the sky
opens up to dozens of glowing
silhouettes presumably other characters
who know peter parker is spider-man from
other universes one of them holds a
spear looks like craven the hunter
others match the shape of rhino there's
another one that kind of looks like
scorpion i'm gonna go deeper into these
in another video too so peter and dr
strange realize that the only way to
seal up these cracks is to complete the
memory wipe spell as it was intended
meaning everyone will forget peter is
spider-man notice how whereas the runes
before were thinner more rushed written
here they are bolder and more
authoritative like the runes cast by
scarlet witch in the vision final battle
so toby and andrew make their final
goodbyes and toby says it's what we do
recalling how aunt may justified why you
should help people and peter explains it
all to mj and he promises he will come
find her just reminds me a lot of that
theme from eternal sunshine how love is
too powerful of a force to be bound by
memory and mj tells peter that she loves
him but she doesn't let him say it back
to her wagering that the first time he
can say it to her on the other side
it'll be so pure and real that that
could be the thing that awakens her and
then so after the spell is complete the
world continues to know that spider-man
exists but the name peter parker means
nothing to them this is crazy because it
means that ned and mj still made it into
mit but with no physical evidence of
peter barker's history with them so in
addition to brainwashing everyone's
memories this spell must also have
warped all of reality to erase documents
any kind of digital records any physical
mark that peter parker left on the world
i mean does a guy have a birth
certificate a social security card i
would say that that should have to
necessitate a new history to be conjured
to replace the peter history that was
erased but and i hate to point this out
but if you think about it peter was
often absent from his major events in
his life from his homecoming dance from
his field trips from his school
competitions he was blipped for five
years it's depressing to realize this
but his erasure is not that disruptive
to his friends lives i mean essentially
this just means mj and ned spent more of
their teenage years alone which for mj
reading a book by herself is just kind
of who she is ned tinkering with his
legos is who he is i mean yeah it's
sadder the more you think about it but
it's true that's why peter makes this
sacrifice because he knows his loved
ones can get by without him and so when
he finds them back in the peter pan
coffee shop himself a kind of peter pan
stuck watching kids grow up and move on
without him however mj still wears the
black dahlia necklace so somewhere deep
down she still loves him in the coffee
cup she gives him reads we are happy to
serve you a cup that he holds on to to
remind himself to serve by the way we
actually saw the sanctum apprentice with
one of those copy cups earlier when she
was trying to fix that same artifact
that thor also broke in ragnarok
that cup also showed up on the dashboard
of the tracksuit mafia in hawkeye
episode 5 and peter almost says to mj i
love you but he stops himself and he
waits upon seeing the band-aid because
he doesn't want to hurt mj anymore so to
protect her for now he walks away peter
visits mae's grave you'll notice the
flowers cover the birth and death dates
i guess because as tony stark observed
when he first met may in civil war we
never do quite know how old mei is happy
shows up doesn't know who peter is but
he compares this feeling to losing tony
and peter sets up his new apartment i am
praying that they can find a way to make
mr dikkovic his landlord you'll notice
he has a ged test prep book and that's
because this guy has no academic record
anymore also we see he sets up his
palpatine lego which was the first we
saw of ned leeds back in homecoming and
he wears a new suit with brighter blues
and swings out past 30 rockefeller
center where the upcoming finale of
hawkeye will be set i don't think we'll
see spider-man swinging into the
background of that but a guy can dream
being a stranger to the community peter
parker relied on is so painful but it
does force this kid to mature into the
selfless hero that his forbearers showed
him how to be at times the life of a
hero is a lonely one but all those
people are still there and they may not
remember but they still love him and one
day he will find his way home that is
everything i found in this
heart-wrenching and beautiful spider-man
film but there's so much more i want to
say about this movie so to support our
channel and help us do that please check
out one of those great merch options at
nyrockstarsmerch.com that strange
entitlement design is calling to you we
also got a kingpin inspired long live
the king shirt you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea loss follow
the new rockstar subscribe to rockstars
for more analysis of everything marvel
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you